you're getting plenty of plaudits from
the audience spud head johnny says
richard you're a top man
carl cartesian said richard dolan is
class
someone wants to know what do you think
this person freddis33 what does richard
think about bob lazar is he legit oh god
by the way thanks for the feedback
that's always nice
um there's plenty more i just oh good
time to read it
there
i'll send them to you to your email it's
it's it's fine thank you it's okay
um
as far as with lazar
i say that because
it's
there there are people who who really
they like me and then there are people
every now and then there's someone who
just hates me
and uh that doesn't like in the old days
i would be like why don't you like me my
mom thinks i'm cool and i'm like why
what what did i ever do to you but
i just realized like you know you can't
you just cannot please everybody that's
just life
um i try my best i try my best to just
do good work and and just leave it at
that as far as what i think about bob
lazar um
yeah when i wrote my second volume of
ufos in the national security state
years ago i agonized over that and all i
tried to do that was back in 09 when i
published that book
um
because i went into my
research with lazar i was very much on
the fence and i didn't know what i
thought and i assume everyone watching
this knows bob lazar claimed to have
seen flying flying saucers
near area 51 in a place he called s4
in nevada
in uh
in late 1988 early 1989.
on i think a total of six occasions
he was interviewed by george knapp in
1989
under a pseudonym originally dennis i
think and then comes out as bob lazar by
the i think in
1990 so um
yes i think i believe was our story no
longer
eric davis recently just said lazar was
full of full of
full of it and uh
i was surprised because
i know other people in that little world
that couldn't connected to davis who
i know that they believe lazar's story
so i was i was a bit surprised when
davis said what he did but
um yes i think so i i don't know that
everything lazar said is true
but that doesn't mean that he's not
being truthful
there's a there's
there's one theory that i find actually
interesting
um
that could square the circle
i mean first of all you've got problems
with those ards
stand and freedom and talked about
lazar's educational issues like he said
he went to mit he never went to mit he
said he went to caltech he never went to
caltech yeah true
two things i would say about that one
look
i remember the 1980s
i lived through the 80s in the early 90s
and
the fact was back then
people
lied lied lied about their credentials
all the time
all the time
i mean look i don't defend the practice
i never did
but i knew a lot of people i used to
write professional resumes for job
seekers
i worked with thousands of people and i
knew like i i can't do background checks
on all these folks but i knew they were
not all truthful about their background
uh one woman finally she was a very nice
lady she was the hr director somewhere
she said yeah i got fired because they
found out that i didn't have this degree
that i said i had it's like it was in
the early 90s like
how many times did that happen so did
lazar lie about his education yeah
probably
um
but actually what i think he did is he
may have audited a couple of courses at
caltech or mit and
for no credit that's what it looks like
to me actually
so i'm like look am i gonna throw his
whole story out because he did that that
to me that's just ridiculous it's silly
um there are people who would say oh
well he lied about that i can't believe
anything he says okay fine fair enough
i'm not going to do that so i want to
look at the story
can it be corroborated look you talked
to george knapp who interviewed lazar
george
has interviewed about 25 other people in
addition to lazar who have had
stories
very similar or that have corroborated
various elements of what bob lazara said
that doesn't prove lazar is truthful but
it
but there's a tremendous amount of
corroboration
and and keep in mind lazar was first to
go public
he wasn't the first to talk to private
researchers but he was the first to go
public he's the reason we learned about
area 51
lazar
he's the reason people knew where to go
to look for the ufos he said they fly
every wednesday over in this location
they start going like how did he know
that he knew something
he knew something and they got arrested
the second time they went out with john
mayer and a couple of other people
and he got in trouble
and he lost his job and his clearance
and whatever
but uh george you know did investigation
of lazar he did find he worked at los
alamos national labs in 1982.
he almost almost certainly did meet with
edward teller who probably got him the
job at eg
in 1988 to do what he did
um yes i think so
so um and then you talk to people who
knew lazar before
oh that i i have a friend named ron
roger who's a great guy
ron knew lazar back back in the day back
earlier before 1989 and ron
you know
what do you say ron's like i'm telling
you man bob lazar is a hundred percent
so
lazar's got people who support him and
i listen to that it doesn't mean that it
informs my entire judgment but
i'm not going to blow off ron rigara's
assessment i i know and like and respect
ron
um
but i believe lazar's story
fundamentally oh so here's the theory
that that um
the late great crazy genius gordon
novell shared with me years ago
gordon was someone who is uh obsessed
with
um
publicizing the technology of something
known as the arv
the legendary alien reproduction vehicle
that was supposedly shown in 19 november
1988 to bradford sorensen
he's a real guy sorensen aviation
executive
uh who saw
three hovering flying saucers at
lockheed's palm uh
big hanger in 1988
he was brought in with a high-level
defense official
okay
so this is a story and and according to
that story that object ran on
the
this is one year before the first paper
on zero point energy comes out
uh-huh what year was this
approximately
yes november 1988.
so it was one year before in fact the
first paper on zpe was uh co-authored by
hal put off put off's all over the place
zero point energy
which has also come
you know conveniently or colloquially
described described as the vacuum
sometimes
so let's say let's say there's a craft
that has something to do with zero point
energy
like pretend
that that's the solution to the flying
saucer energy mystery
let's say that they can exploit
the ether or zero point like what tesla
believes in this i think and
you know
maybe it's true
so
if it is true and let's say we're on a
team to build a flying saucer
utilizing zpe
but we know that there's competitors out
there
and we don't want them to
be on our path they don't we don't want
them to compete with us so what might we
do we might we might psychologically
profile a guy like lazar
knowing that he could be compromised
knowing that he has this attitude where
he just didn't seem to give a [ __ ] about
certain things
and
you give him fake information
so you talk to him about
this thing running on element 115
jokingly referred to as unobtainium
because it's so impossible to get a a
stable isotope of it that that lasts for
more than a split second
we don't know how to do it
yes they were able
recently like 10 years ago to create
some level of element 115 but it can't
you can't get a stable version of it
so here's lazar talking back in 1989
like saying yes i was told that it runs
on element 115 not that we manufactured
but that was brought here by these
aliens i think is what he said mm-hmm
so unobtainium so if we were on the team
and we wanted to throw off our
competitors we might say we might make
up a [ __ ] and bull story about element
115
and then the competitors would say oh
crap
we can't build this let's just give up
not gonna work
like that that was that was gordon
novell's
theory which he shared with me many
years ago and
i thought oh
it's actually kind of interesting that's
intriguing maybe there's something to
that but i don't know
why was lazar told what he was
were they playing a game with him
anything is possible
anything's possible it's like working in
you know researching in a hall of
mirrors
what is what is the real and what is the
reflection
it's difficult as hell sometimes so
that's why i think like
um
lazar's story is interesting but it's
also not
it's not a make or break thing for
ufology as a whole
fortunately
um
sorry what parts of the story do you
feel are legitimate not just what he was
told uh the party where he said it
corresponds to the truth where he said i
saw a craft and went into it it was very
small and i couldn't get into it i could
practically fit in i believe that
i don't think he's making that up
i spoke to lazar about just two weeks
ago oh and yes how about that
not for a podcast and he's a
pertinacious little fellow
and i want to desperately say pugnacious
pertinacious he's stubbornly persistent
and he
he
i want
i'm more interested in how is the strong
force associated with gravity because
he's made that claim he calls the strong
force gravity number one or gravity
number two so i'm extremely interested
in speaking with him well yeah i mean
he's lizard i met him once and
um but like you could see when you
listen to him and you watch him i've
watched him a lot and uh
he he's a real intellectual
and like a lot of these intellectuals
you said pertinacious sure
they don't all have the best social
skills you know you're talking about
people who are analytical problem
solvers and um
and they're out of the box thinkers
lazar is absolutely an out of the box
type of thinker too and i think that's
why he actually was brought in so he was
a very smart smart guy
who didn't think like a normal person he
put a jet engine on his cars what got
him in the newspapers in los alamos all
those years ago that's how he met ted
tell her
so he's
he's kind of like a crazy genius
who is on the quiet side
i i'm not you know i i'm not going to
give a psychological profile of lazar
but he's clearly a hyper analytical kind
of a guy who
you know
is probably not it is not always easy to
deal with probably i'm just going to
guess
ben in toronto at ben in toronto wants
to know the when the former head of the
israeli space program hay mached made
the statement last year about a galactic
federation do you think he's making that
based on some facts or his own personal
beliefs
yeah that's a great question um i think
probably a bit of both that's my hunch i
have not spoken to hayama shed um
i don't know him personally he's very
advanced in years
this is a man who he ran
israel's what was it there's i think
either their space agency
i think that's what it was and he had he
had some senior position within their
defense establishment in general terms
so he he was a guy like you can assume
he probably was briefed on certain
things i mean israel's active with their
space exploration
um
they've they've got unacknowledged nukes
obviously that no one ever is allowed to
talk about but they clearly have at
least 200 nuclear missiles
um that they get a pass for by the
global community for some reason
but uh so they have they have a very
highly highly advanced extremely like
some of the most advanced genius
scientists in the world
who
deal with space and he's one of these
people he's dealt with that so i have to
assume he's been briefed and that he
knows some things and that he knows what
he's talking about on the other hand
um
yeah when we talk about the galactic
federation first of all when we talk
about donald trump probably knowing
about it
that could be absolutely like he might
have just known for real uh
would surprise me if donald trump didn't
know something about this
but when he starts talking about the
galactic federation this is something
that you
hear in fact in the new eight we talked
about the new age community a little
while ago like this is a big thing with
the new age ufo community the galactic
federation sometimes the galactic
federation of light
and uh for my part
maybe i'm does this have to do with the
pleiades the pleia needs some galactic
sometimes they're brought into it what
is it called the pleiades right the
pleiadians yeah i heard of this yeah
they get they get roped in sometimes yes
sometimes no there's different groups
supposedly that are involved and i don't
know how anyone really knows the truth
on this to be honest with you but
but um
maybe i'm the one who's wrong maybe
maybe there is a galactic federation and
i just
but i don't personally believe that
there is
so when i hear hayaim i should talk
about this i think
he's probably working off of
you know people in the ufo community
edgar mitchell was the same way
uh astronaut edgar mitchell i mean i i
knew i wasn't close friends with him but
he
he wrote endorsements my for my first
three or four books
i was very grateful to him and he and i
talked with him and
he he clearly knew certain things but he
was also working
with researchers in the community and
his own beliefs and i think that's
probably the case with with mr eschat so
i i suspect it's a combination of both
and then you know the other thing is
when you get when you get to that age
and i i
i read his statements
he struck me as someone who is still
very much in command of his faculty so
don't i don't want to be misunderstood
here but i also will say when someone
gets to a certain age they either stop
giving a damn and they just talk and
that could very well be the case with
him
but it also can happen
i mean i saw this in my with my own
father before he died
um
the stories change
the stories change my dad was a new york
city cop and uh i knew all of i knew all
the stories
they changed around what age they
changed precipitously he died at the age
of 79 two months a month before he
turned 80.
and uh i would say in the last
for him the last two years
he would tell me
it always goes back to brooklyn and
dealing with the gangs you know that was
like his glory ears and um
i remember saying to him hey that's not
how that story went down he says what
are you talking about richie i was
always richie to him
that's what it was and i'm like no
not really i wasn't going to argue with
my dad but i knew the stories changed so
things do happen and cognitive things
happen to people get older sometimes and
it can happen at different ages with my
dad it was
after he turned 75
maybe 76
uh and i don't know that that's the case
with mr i should i don't know but but i
do say like when you deal with very
elderly witnesses
i'm just sorry but you have to keep that
in mind
you got to keep in mind the possibility
of cognitive decline and stories
changing and it can happen and it has
happened
sometimes not always